question is do you think that women's
sexual Liberation was good for women
so
good
when you say sexual Liberation can you
expand on that being a hoe so being
partially being being able to Hope but
particularly the development of birth
control in the 1960s that's what changed
the game right because before when girls
slept around there was always the
consequence of possibly getting pregnant
but once you added birth control into it
it takes away the consequence because
you can get an IUD you have a 99 Point
whatever percent chance of not getting
pregnant
um what was the question again
is women's sexual Liberation good for
women
I'm gonna say no okay just because of
what you've I don't believe I don't like
the idea of birth control I don't like
the fact that it was created just for
women
um so yeah I'm anti-vat so okay what
about you I think
um oh God
it def I I
it didn't
I I yeah I'd say it didn't just because
of the fact that um
I feel like
women
um
so I'm trying to like think of like a
best way to say it basically no I don't
agree that it has helped women
um to be liberating
um but then again
when it comes to birth control
I feel like I don't necessarily feel
like birth control helped women be more
liberating necessarily
um
I didn't I don't think they do it for
men they do it for themselves but I'm
not not to have sex
um whenever whenever or wherever they
wanted
women women so women aren't on birth
control to have sex whenever they want
some women choose not to have children
um regardless not everyone wants to have
children
um so when it but like the only purpose
of birth control is to have sex without
having kids no but I mean
um I mean I know some people do it for
acne too I'll put that in there and for
menstrual yes yes yes
um but that's why I say it's not solely
right yeah just to not have babies but
wouldn't you say the majority is it's
four it is the majority it is majority
is yeah
um I need to preface this by saying that
I can't have children okay so I know
nothing about birth control I've never
had a period in my life
um speaking to the mic I've never sorry
you're right I'll tell you what let me
bring it around here
um I've never had a period in my life
I've uh never obviously never taken
birth control don't need to
um but
my general views on sexual Liberation
are that
um yes it's helped because I mean
realistically if it if we're all under
the illusion right that women were
having great orgasms and you know and
really enjoying sex with their forced
marriage husbands like I just don't
think that's a reality I'm almost
certain that I know people from two
generations before me you know my
grandma and whatever that that didn't
even enjoy sex and I bet you're bottomed
on the reason I didn't enjoy sex is not
because sex is not enjoyable for them if
it's done right it's because they never
met a match she was with one man her
whole life like I don't know but how can
you know that's what you want right
um on the other hand I don't think that
um we we don't do as well in
relationships yes right I'm sorry out of
relationships so for example I mean I
struggle to orgasm more with uh casual
Partners it takes me at least a few
times to to get into it and get
comfortable with them and whatever I
think that's our that's our what do you
call it it's like have
like a like a fear you know what I mean
it's like a you need to get to know
someone because especially sex is a very
intimate act and it can make you as a
woman I think so I hope you'd all agree
feel it so so if um if you're saying
that women tend to have better sex in
relationships wouldn't it make more
sense that like back then people used to
get married and have a relationship yeah
and then they'd be in one long-term
relationship because I think that number
one the sex education that you have
before that relationship is never it's
never good enough to let to tell people
exactly what they need to be doing
um number two I think that to be quite
honest with you like in our current you
know climate we have multiple
relationships through our lives which
teach us things I don't think we're
monogamous creatures well they also
traumatize you oh yeah of course they do
but yeah but life is traumatizing in so
many ways you don't think it's like
better to have less relationships than
more I mean I mean to a certain degree
because because every time you have you
know if you have a relationship you you
have a heartbreak right to us to a
certain degree I'm not done I'm not
denying yeah but at the same time I just
don't think you can learn everything you
need to learn from one relationship your
whole life it's just not feasible what
are the things that you think they're
not learning
well
because arguably
your grandparents right so you said that
you should argue me she wasn't having
good sex but then what was her what's
her metric for good and bad sex well I
mean look I didn't sit there and have
like I'm just curious what would the
metric be
um because how would she know if she's
only had sex with one person but that's
exactly my point yeah but I'm saying
like like so I'll give you a stat right
if a woman's a virgin when she gets
married and she has an 80 chance of
being in a happy marriage after 10 years
80 chance okay um on the other hand if a
girl's had sex with more than five
Partners it drops to 25 percent
so yeah and and and I think in the
modern day and age most guys will pray
for five Partners
[Music]
so I mean look this is the only problem
I have with Statistics as much as I like
to follow them to a certain degree
obviously we have to right but I just
think you know when it comes to
reportedly happy marriages I mean really
what is a fulfilling relationship
a fulfilling relationship well one one
that La I think one metric you can use
is how long it lasts one that lost but
but I mean realistically realistically
if if we're going by the premise that
women the the statistic you just said
which means that women would be faithful
to their husband their whole lives right
do you really think their husbands are
being faithful to them so so is their
marriage actually happy and are they
really happy would they really be happy
if they knew the realities of their
marriage which is probably that their
husband was playing around at some point
so so two things one there's a really
big misconception that that a lot of men
are sleeping with everybody but and the
reason that is the reason women think
that men cheat all the time is because
we're all sleeping with the same ones
because if you survey 100 of women on
what they want in a guy they list 20 of
men sometimes 15 sometimes five percent
of men when it comes to dating apps
women only swipe right between five to
twenty percent of the time so it's a
very small percentage of men that even
have the option to cheat
so well well yeah okay but the thing is
I feel like you're talking about stuff
that's modern right because
realistically if we're talking about
marriages in the way that they used to
be that would mean going back in time
when women were oppressed by marriage
marriage which means that realistically
the husbands having the male privilege
they had would have much more likely
been able to go out and play away I had
an uncle in the a great uncle sorry in
the Navy and he used to he's had a wife
back here in England and he used to go
to ports in Africa he loved black women
so I've probably got some black
African cousins somewhere
no but I'm just saying that obviously if
that that was a staple back in the day
that was how things worked I don't think
it was with every relationship I think
it was a lot well but I'm saying it's
still even like women haven't changed
like women still want the same things
they're just pickier and pickier and
pickier so it's a smaller and smaller
percentage of men so so what I'm saying
is the majority of men don't have the
option to cheat it's hard for a guy to
get laid like on dating apps like where
you can be the most honest about what
you want right women only swipe right
five percent of the time where men swipe
right 50 of the time I mean men will
have sex with a hole in the wall
but to kind of continue on that point if
you want to make a comparison between
the modern day and and
um but back in the day men had a lot
less access really we lived in small
communities and only people could sleep
with the people that lived in your
immediate vicinity your uncle was
different because he was a sailor now
men have a lot more access through
dating apps but the thing is I think
what you're forgetting is that the
reality of it was is that men
um you know I don't I don't know the
exact time ago that it was but women
actually had to stay in the house so men
were allowed to gallivant and do
whatever they were talking in the mic
sorry men were allowed to gallivant
around do whatever they wanted you know
like back in the Victorian times ride
horses around the place right while the
women just had to sit at home and wait
for them to come
but Freedom comes with responsibility
right so men also had to fight in Wars
well we got to stay home right so they
they were forced like they they get
drafted so so you know women we have my
body my choice men don't when they get
drafted
yeah but I mean look we're not living in
times where people get drafted to war
anymore are we I mean well because we're
not in a major war but if that I mean
look look what happened in um Ukraine
yeah in Ukraine all the feminism went
out the window when when War times came
they're like you know what bring me back
to the kitchen but that but there go
there goes where I said their specific
roles in society I do understand that
men and women have different strengths
and you know one of one of the things
we're not born to do is fight really but
I definitely think that the reality is
is that we've hacked the reason why
feminism even got so much traction the
reason why we're here today is because
women have felt like we've had to fight
for too long I certainly have felt like
that in my life and I've had a
relatively easy life I like as I could
imagine in terms of women you know what
I mean like I'm probably in the I'm
probably in the like top [ __ ] 10
percent of women with good lives and
privilege you know what I mean so I can
imagine that
um you know there were women in so what
if you felt like you've had to fight for
in 2022
um
2022. well yeah I don't feel like I have
to fight so much now it was in 2010 I
don't know whatever
um
I think I think back then it was just
I mean I was I was a model I was very
like fresh young fat I got
very much predated upon by men um I
would even say that
uh to go as far as to say that it has
unfortunately like left scars on me
um probably the reason why uh you know
like we're talking about the
um however many menu how I do struggle
to find more meaningful relationships
um but again I you know that's that that
was what I feel like was the oppression
you know it was like oh you're just a
pre like men literally saw me as that
just root face like they can manipulate
me use me well but that's that's the job
to be pretty
I'm not saying that modeling was the
reason why before modeling it was that
you know what I mean so even before
modeling yeah yeah because to me like
being beautiful is an advantage there's
there's like people are treated pretty
privileged people are treated better if
they're pretty they get shorter
sentencing like for present time no I'm
serious like that you get you're more
likely to get a job interview like being
attract like in the top 20 of beauty so
being being in the top 20 of beauty
where you could actually get a modeling
contract like that's a huge advantage in
the world yeah no well that no the worst
advantages that I had I'm not saying
that wasn't but um
I mean look certainly we have to
remember that my mental state when I was
16 17 18 when every goal first went out
to have sex and like it was not the same
like sex was painful 20 times before it
became all right
um